[موسيقى]
ممكن نرجع مع بعض كده شويه كم سنه لورا
فاكرين يوم الجمعه ايه اللي كنا بنستناه
دايما بيجي مع جورنال يوم الجمعه
مجله ميكي المجله دي كنا بنستناها من
اسبوع للاسبوع ونفضل نقرا فيها طول
الاسبوع لحد ما يجي العدد الجديد وفي اخر
السنه نستنى المجلد الكبير اللي بيجمع كل
النسخ كلها فيها مع بعض عشان نحتفظ بها
عندنا في البيت عشان كده النهارده انا
اخترت شخصيات مشهوره جدا في مجله ميكي
عشان احكي لكم على ثلاث قصص اعرفهم بدره
القصه الاولانيه مني
اتخرجت وما حبتش تشتغل بالكليه اللي
اتخرجت منها ليه لان هي كانت رافضه فكره
التدريس معتبره ان هي مهنه روتينيه جدا
لحد ما في يوم من الايام في مقابله قبلت
شخصيه لاول مره بتقابلها في حياتها
الشخصيه دي
كانت بتتكلم معاها وبتقول لها انا بشتغل
في مدرسه دوليه وانت ليه ما بتشتغليش انت
كمان
قالت لها هشتغل ايه انا عمري اصلا ما
اشتغلت معنديش خبره اصلا واشتغل كمان في
المدرسه دولي ازاي يعني كده يا ستي جربي
انت مش هتخسري حاجه
بصراحه منك فكرت فعلا في الفكره بس قعدت
في دماغها بتدور بتقول طب هعمل ايه في
المسئوليات اللي عندي دي كلها لو اشتغلت
بيت ومسؤوليه وولاد وبعدين انا بعاني 30
سنه كمان ايه ومع ذلك هي جربت وراحت قدمت
واتقبلت عملت
انت تمام انت معنا الاسبوع الجاي تعالي
نمضي العقد مع بعض
راحت الاسبوع الجاي بس للاسف الهده ما
كانش موجود وكان مكانه واحده تانيه فقالت
لها ممكن تعمليه
انا ايه المشكله انا واثقه في نفسي انا
هعمل تاني عملت وبعد ما خلصت قالت لها بصي
انت تمام قوي بس
اهي بقى دائما مشكله بس دي بتيجي بعد
الكلام الحلو بس انت عندك شويه حاجات
عايزه تزبطيها ايه رايك دوري على كورسات
تعمليها تضبطي الحاجات دي عندك واحنا
مستنينك تعالي
الحاجات دي الصراحه وقفت مني
القصه الثانيه لميكي ميكي قاعد على
السوشيال ميديا زهق زي ما كنا بنعمل وهو
بيدور في السوشيال ميديا طلع له كورس
مجانا لمده ثلاث شهور الله انتم عارفين
احنا كلنا طبعا اي حاجه مجانا ان احنا
فيها على طول اكيد
فقدم ودخل الكورس ذاكر واجتهد ونجح وجابت
92% في الكورس ده بعتوا له ميله قالوا له
تعالى عشان هتاخد الشهاده بتاعتك كمان
شهاده يعني كورس مجانا وهاخد كمان شهاده
المكان العظيم ده هو فين اكتشف ان هو
هيروح مؤسسه دوليه مشهوره جدا اعتقد يعني
ان كل اللي فرد في مصر يحب يروح لو عرف
يروحوها اصلا
وراح يستلم الشهاده بتاعته
القصه الثالثه لديزيدك
كانت بتنقل من مكان لمكان فكانت واخده
بنتها تقدم لها في مدرسه
وطبعا زي ما احنا بنعمل دايما بنمشي على
اللوكيشن اللوكيشن وصلها للمكان المدرسه
نفس الاسم بس شكل تاني مختلف فنزلت بتبص
عليها كده
مش دي المدرسه اللي انا كنت جاياها وانا
انضحك عليا ولا ايه وهي عماله تفكر واتكلم
نفسها جالها السكيورتي قال لها ايوه يا
فندم وحضرتك جايه تقدم عندنا قالت له قدم
عندكم المدرسه دولي
قال لها اه ده في مدرسين كثير بيعملوا
ابلكيشن دلوقتي
هنا وبدات تفكر
السؤال دلوقتي التلات قصص دي
ايه الحاجه اللي بتجمعهم هم التلاته
صدفه كل واحده من القصص دي الصدفه هي اللي
خدت كل شخصيه منهم لمحطه جديده في حياته
السؤال تاني هي ممكن القصص دي تحصل لشخص
واحد الحياه اه هي حصلت لي التلات قصص دي
هي ثلاث محطات حصلت في حياتي كل محطه سلمت
التانيه من غير ما اعرف خالص يعني في قصه
الاولانيه
انا ما وقفتش
بس استفزيت الصراحه ورجعت متضايقه جدا
روحت البيت هناك عماله بدور في السوشيال
ميديا انا عايزه اطلع كم الغضب الموجود
ليه يعني ايه المشكله اللي فيا وانا بدور
قابلت القوس بالصدفه ده في المحطه التانيه
ولما رحت استلمت الشهاده من المؤسسه
الدوليه المشهوره دي اكتشفت ان انا بدات
اخد هنا برنامج هم كانوا عاملينه جديد
لمدرسين لاول مره مش بس كده انا من اللحظه
دي بدات
مزايا كتيره باخدها من بعد برنامج اللي
انا دخلته معهم ده كورسز
حاجات كتيره جدا فعلا خدتني ونقلتني نقطه
ومرحله تانيه عشان كده في المحطه الثالثه
لما رحت وقدمت في المدرسه دي اتقبلت على
طول ومش بس كده اخدت كمان ثقه ومركز في
المدرسه دي بسرعه جدا
المحطات فضلت تاخدني من مكان لمكان وما
تفتكروش ان كل محطه كانت سهله كده لا كل
واحده كان فيها حاجات كثيره قابلتني
صعوبات كانت ممكن توقفني في اي لحظه بس
انا كملت وفضلت تمشي معي كده لحد ما دخلت
برنامج تابع برضو للمؤسسه الدوليه دي
البرنامج ده اسمه
دخلت وفي البرنامج ده كان برضو كان صدفه
المؤسسه دي كانت بتعمله لاول مره لمدرسين
الموجودين في محافظات الكبرى زي القاهره
واسكندريه لان هم كانوا قبل كده بيعملوها
في المحافظات باعتبار المحافظات ما بتاخدش
حقها كفايه فما دخلت دي فضلت سنه كامله
بجهز في البرنامج ده واشتغلت انا ومجموعه
من المدرسين زمايلي اللي في البرنامج
عملنا استمر لمده شهر ونصف بنشرح للمدرسين
المصريين طبعا
اساليب التدريس الحديثه اللي بتخلي الطالب
اوتانا يعني يعتمد على نفسه وان مدرس مجرد
ما هو ان هو
1800 مدرس على مستوى الجمهوريه حضروا
الحصص دي وبجد حقيقي هي عمل الصدا جامد
جدا جدا لدرجه
المسؤولين عن بروجرام تواصلوا معانا
وقالوا لنا احنا عايزين نجهز تكون متوافقه
مع مؤتمر اللي هيتعمل في مصر في شهر 11
ايوه هنعمل ايه الفكره جديده هنعمل ايه
عايزين نعمل نشرح دروس عن التغيرات
والمناخيه
[موسيقى]
يعني
الدروس دي موجوده وردي في المناهج المصريه
الجديده بس انا بحكم شغلي في المدرسه
الدولي ان انا ما ليش علاقه بالمدارس
للمناهج المصريه
زمايلي كلهم عندهم الدروس فجهزين طب انا
هعمل ايه انا قعدت افكر هتصرف ايه وهجهز
ايه في
للماده دي او دي لحد ما بالصدفه لقيت قصه
كوميكس قابلتني ده كان الاعلان بتاع
المؤتمر
لحد ما قابلتني قابلتني قصه
بتحكي عن التغيرات المناخيه اسبابها
ومشاكلها وحلولها كمان قريتها وانا مش
حاسه فعلا بجد بالوقت يعني من اولها
لاخرها وبعدين فكرت قلت طب واحنا
ليه ما نستخدمش الطريقه دي في تعليم
الطلبه كمان
بدات اعمل في الموضوع اكثر ان الكوميكس
بدرسها افيد للطلبه من ان هم يشوفوا فيلم
كرتون في ايه اولا رقم واحد الطالب بيقدر
ان هو يربط الصوره بالكلمه فهو بيستوعب
اكتر وفي نفس الوقت بيقدر ريكول او يفتكر
المعلومه اسرع رقم 2 بتنقل المعلومات
ايا كانت حجمها معقده او لو كانت طويله في
وقت قصير جدا رقم 3 الطالب نفسه بيقرا
بسرعته هو ما بيقراش بسرعه الفيديو
فكرت فيها واخدت الكوميكس دي وطبقتها على
درس عندي من الدروس اللي موجوده عندي في
المدرسه في الطلبه حولت الدرس
وبدات اشتغل معهم
عمليا الموضوع كان ناجح جدا ومش بس كده
انا بدات كمان نطبق عليها
معهم بمعنى ايه اولا بقيت اجيب لهم مثلا
الكوميكس فاضي واقول لهم اخلقولي انتم
الستوري
الولاد كانوا بيعملوا ابداع في الافكار
واكتشفت ان دي كمان بتعلم الطلبه حاجه ان
هم ممكن يبصوا للموقف من كذا جهه لان كل
واحد خلق حاجه مختلفه من نفس الصوره فاعا
عارف ان الموقف واحد ممكن نشوفه من اربع
جهات مختلفه وكلهم صح على فكره
حاجه تانيه اديتهم كوميكس في كلام وكل
حاجه وبعدين قلت لهم غيروا الواقع بس ده
مش الواقع بتاع احمد حلمي غير واقع القصه
دي وفعلا اولاد ابدعوا في تغييرها من ضمن
الحاجات كمان المميزه للكوميكس ان انا
ممكن اسال الطالب قل لي الفرق ما بين
بدايه القصه ونهايتها فهيقارن من غير ما
يطير لا يرجع لورا ولا يقدم لقدام ممكن
اجي في اي لحظه في ان اللحظات في وسط
الستوري واساله واقول له هو ايه اللي
هيحصل بعد كده
الطالب بادئه كمان ضمن الحاجات بقى يقرا
الكلمه ونشوف بتاعه الكارت اللي موجوده
فبيربطه فده بيعمل عمليه ربط ما بين معنى
الكلمه وما بين الكوميكس نفسها
فكره تدريس الكوميكس للطلبه وبالذات
الاصغر سنا فعلا فكره ناجحه جدا جدا ولو
اتطبقت فعلا حقيقي هتعمل يعني
خطوه
كويسه مع الطلبه الصغيرين هتخلي خيالهم
يتفتح هيبدعوا بمعنى الكلمه
عايزه اقول لكم انه
الصدفه او مجموعه الصدفه اللي حصلت لي دي
من بدايتها لحد اخرها هي اللي كان السبب
ان انا اكون موجوده عندكم هنا على
الاستوديو النهارده وبتكلم عن الفكره دي
وانا الصراحه ما بعتبرهاش صدف انا بعتبرها
فرص فرص جت لحد عندي وانا اخدتها واشتغلت
عليها انا كنت متاكده ان هي هتوصلني لحاجه
في الاخر لا بامانه لا بس اشتغلت عليها
عارفه ان انا هستفيد منها بس هوصل لحاجه
في الاخر لا ما كنتش متاكده من كده فعايزه
اقول لك انه لو لو فرصه جات لك او صدفه
جات لك خدها واشتغل عليها هتوصلك للحاجه
للاخر لا مش مشكله بسبب لانه رب صدفه غيرت
مجرى حياه شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]